hagamos a un lado las cuestiones morales
y de justicia y pensemos con
detenimiento si es que este rescate
podría funcionar porque francamente si
esto no funciona entonces es algo que
definitivamente no debería preocuparnos
a ninguno de nosotros y sí sí funciona
entonces si deberíamos preocuparnos por
las cuestiones de igualdad y de
moralidad digamos que este es el banco y
es un banco que no está muy bien que
digamos tiene de este lado sus bienes y
de este otro lado están sus obligaciones
aquí del lado izquierda están los bienes
del lado derecho las obligaciones y en
sus libros vemos que tiene el valor de
los bonos dados como colaterales también
conocidos como obligaciones de deuda
garantizada con un valor de 5 billones y
lo que está diciendo el gobierno es que
bueno en este caso tenemos que el banco
le ha prestado al banco a cierta
cantidad 8 billones por lo que quizás
estos 8 billones tengan que ser pagados
el siguiente mes
gran temor es que el banco ve siente
temor y quiere recuperar este dinero que
prestó ya que tienen miedo de que si le
siguen prestando a este banco no saben
cuál va a ser el valor de estas
obligaciones de deuda garantizada o
bonos dados como colaterales y es un
temor legítimo porque si estos o deje
objetos de deuda garantizada valen los 5
billones entonces se tiene un equilibrio
de 4 billones el total de los bienes es
de 12 12 billones menos 8 millones de
obligaciones nos queda una igualdad de 4
billones bueno pero qué sucede si estos
ejes valen solamente un billón si esto
vale un billón y éstos valen 7 billones
sólo tendremos 8 billones en bienes y 8
billones en obligaciones nuestro
equilibrio será igual a cero así que no
tendremos equilibrio o aún peor
imaginemos que estás o dejes valen 0
tendríamos un equilibrio negativo por lo
que este banco idea la bancarrota se
volvería el siguiente lehman brothers
por lo
el prestamista obtendría solamente por
esos 8 billones que prestó ya que estos
ejes valen 0 y los demás valen 7
billones pues sólo recibiría estos 7
billones por lo que de estos 8 billones
que prestaron sólo recibirían 7 lo que
dice el gobierno es que bueno para
evitar que el banco b retire el préstamo
que le ha dado al banco a vamos a
comprar esas obligaciones de deuda
garantizada a un precio que
esencialmente permita que esto salve al
banco aún cuando esto lo dejes realmente
valgan cero
el tesoro no va a pagar cero ya que si
lo hiciera pues este banco se iría a la
bancarrota y sería otro lehman brothers
así que el tesoro lo que hará es
esencialmente pagar los cinco billones
por lo que tomamos estos cinco billones
compramos estos o dejes y de pronto pues
aquí ya no tenemos o dejes esto se
vuelve efectivo y su argumento es que si
ellos hacen esto aunque sea muy injusto
porque esto es esencialmente darles un
cheque por 5 billones si se asume que
estos ejes no valen
pues es un cheque que se les está
otorgando a los acreedores y a los
deudores de este banco pero hagamos todo
esto a un lado y supongamos que esto
funciona que ahora el banco me dice
bueno pues ahora este banco tiene este
efectivo como bien ya no tienes uso de
hesse por lo que este banco ya tiene un
valor en libros positivo así que voy a
continuar con el préstamo que les hice
pero no es tan sencillo ya que atrás de
estas o de hesse hay otros bienes en
este libro y en la mayoría de los libros
de los bancos éstos serán los bonos
dados como colaterales de lo peorcito lo
peor de lo peor y aquí tenemos otras
cosas que son un poquito menos riesgosas
tenemos las obligaciones de deuda
garantizada
alternativa a son préstamos que se les
da a personas que no necesariamente son
las mejores pero tienen calificaciones
de crédito buenas aunque no están dando
dinero y están fabricando sus ingresos
mediante los préstamos que obtienen y de
éstos algunos pueden que sean un poco
más riesgosos y otros menos riesgo
por encima de estos tenemos inmuebles
comerciales obligaciones de deuda
garantizada de inmuebles comerciales así
que le ponemos aquí inmuebles
comerciales y encima de esto podemos
tener préstamos comerciales para
compañías regulares o incluso podemos
tener préstamos a equilibrios privados
que es aún mejor
estos son equilibrios privados
y eso es para mostrarles que esto no es
lo único feo de estas obligaciones de
deuda garantizadas estos son los
peorcitos podemos pensar en esto como
que si la leche que se está echando a
perder no tuviera mal olor pues no nos
daríamos cuenta que se está echando a
perder y esta es la situación estas o de
hesse parece muy mala hora pero hace
seis meses estas o dgs se parecían mucho
a estas o dejes a alternativas como
lucen ahora y la forma en la que estas o
de hesse se veían hace seis meses es
como ahora se ven estos o dejes de
inmuebles comerciales así que esto es
solamente la punta del iceberg
tenemos un problema aquí el gobierno
llega invierte 5 billones comprando
estos bienes de valor cuestionable y nos
dice a nosotros que ya se ha solucionado
el problema pero el banco ve no es un
tonto seguramente son más prudentes que
el banco a ellos no compraron
estos bienes de baja calificación
pero no me sorprendería que el banco
también tuviera algunos de estos bienes
que no son tan buenos en su hoja de
balance
las alternativas también tiene algo feo
que es el préstamo a que este es uno de
sus bienes también puede que tengan
préstamos al equilibrio privado o
también préstamos a comercios el punto
es que este banco puede revisar sus
propios bienes y pueden ver que el valor
fundamental detrás de éstos se está
deteriorando cualquiera que hable sobre
la economía actual sabe que la economía
está en recesión los consumidores ya no
pueden gastar tanto como antes de hecho
los consumidores no tenían el año pasado
ningún ahorro esto quiere decir que
tienen que tomar prestado dinero para
impulsar su consumo la única forma en
que podemos tener el incremento en el
consumo en este tipo de ambiente es que
ya sea se incrementan los salarios que
no está sucediendo o que las personas
pueden pedir prestado más dinero y ya
sabemos que de crédito ya no es tan
fácil de conseguir así que si ustedes
son el banco ve les daría confianza a
ustedes el hecho de que el gobierno sin
importar cuestiones morales haga esto de
comprar estos bienes les daría confianza
y seguir prestando al banco a pues no
porque ustedes están viendo en su propia
hoja de balance que estos bienes se
están deteriorando y francamente ustedes
tienen préstamos con otras personas
tienen un préstamo del banco se del
banco e a lo mejor de algún fondo
también tienen un préstamo y aquí tienen
su equilibrio así que aquí hay un
problema doble aquí tienen todos esos
préstamos que quizás ustedes tengan que
devolver y entregar en efectivo en el
futuro y están viendo esta tendencia no
son tontos se están dando cuenta de los
riesgos que se están incrementando y que
esto no era la única cosa fea de aquí
hay otras clases de bienes que también
se están deteriorando esto está
perdiendo valor eso también se está
deteriorando así que quizás esta crisis
en el crédito no se debe a estas o dgs
se debe más bien a que este banquero
está siendo prudente está diciendo saben
que necesitamos ser cautos el lado
izquierdo de mi hoja de balance se está
deteriorando necesito recuperar este
dinero en él
y en el mejor interés de los dueños de
mi equilibrio o de mis accionistas o de
los que compraron mis bonos así que aún
cuando no existiera toda esta
controversia aún cuando george bush no
hubiera dado ese discurso controversial
de tener un armageddon financiero si yo
fuera un banquero prudente aún estaría
temeroso de el préstamo que le hice a
este otro banco aun cuando el gobierno
comprará estos o dejes y ahora encima de
esto si yo trabajo en la industria
financiera el banco ve es prudente se
dan cuenta que las cosas se están
deteriorando quieren ser cautos pero
francamente cuando gusta y paulson y
bernanke aparecen en televisión diciendo
a todo el mundo que tienen que aprobar
esta ley y si no va a ocurrir un
precipicio
de hecho palabras que ellos usaron
precipicio o armageddon financiero y
aquí no sé si exactamente ellos los
dijeron o fue algo que se publicó
después pero es algo que se ha estado
escuchando armageddon financiero y que
sólo está al día
mi pregunta con todo esto así ustedes es
sin importar de si el gobierno compra
estos o dejes este tipo de lenguaje les
proporciona a ustedes algún tipo de
confianza si ustedes fueran el banco ve
pues yo fuera el director de este banco
y me estoy dando cuenta de que las cosas
no están yendo bien y estoy aumentando
la tasa de intereses de los préstamos
que estoy haciendo pero de pronto el
presidente de los eeuu el secretario del
tesoro y el director de la reserva
federal usan este lenguaje que ningún
oficial electo no ha usado antes estar a
unos días del precipicio financiero o
del armagedón financiero caray pues
definitivamente no voy a hacer ningún
préstamo aún cuando ellos compren estos
bienes y agreguemos otro elemento a este
panorama este plan requiere de una
subasta en reversa les dicen oigan todos
tengo un millón de dólares
quien quiere vender su hipoteca por el
menor precio pues adivinen las personas
que están dispuestas a vender su
hipoteca por lo más barato son
probablemente los más desesperados de
todos y si alguien participa de ésta
vastas estas son las personas que van a
estar en mi lista roja y esos van a ser
los bancos a los que menos les voy a
prestar porque ya sabemos que están
desesperados solo están cubriendo su
hoja de balance mientras pueden solo
están esperando que los rescate el
gobierno si están dispuestos a tomar el
rescate del gobierno estos van a ser los
bancos a los que yo no los voy a querer
prestar de cualquier manera lo dejamos
aquí en este momento pero sólo quería
mostrarles que cuando el presidente y su
comitiva asustan al mundo y dicen que
tratan de salvar la economía no
mencionan el hecho de que aún cuando se
pueda dar el rescate sin importar qué
injusto sea probablemente se va a
terminar en la misma situación e incluso
esto podría empeorar la situación y eso
es algo que quiero que entiendan todos
ustedes es como cuando empezaron a
limitar el número de acciones que uno
podía vender en el corto plazo diciendo
sabes que no puedes vender las acciones
de los bancos abc inmediatamente esto
hizo que todas las personas pusieran
atención y dijeran
el gobierno sabe algo que nosotros no
sabemos y no quiero tener nada que ver
con los bancos a veces ya que
probablemente estos bancos sean de los
peorcitos que están en la peor situación
posible nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo